[Music]
new at 11 o'clock ccsd is in the process
of selling two acres of land in the
southwest valley not too far from
rainbow and blue diamond to some that
might just look like a big dirt lot but
there's actually a whole lot of history
underneath that site is home to what
could be the last cold war bomb shelter
in las vegas built back in the 1950s in
case of an atomic emergency you're
looking at a tour the county did back in
2013 there's enough room for about 30
people
ccsd has owned the land since the early
20s in fact there used to be a school
there a long time ago the land itself
valued at 990 thousand dollars
sealed bids will be open tomorrow during
uh the board of trustees meeting i'm
sure there's going to be so much it's
just for the conversation factor to be
able to walk into that
those bomb shelters it's actually really
fascinating to look at it harkens back
to the post oppenheimer days where in
school remember that under the desk
you'd always be talking about getting
below ground even if it's the basement
that's a whole other level yeah so we'll
let you know what happens and who's the
lucky lucky bidder absolutely still
ahead on channel a